tennis Legend like arguably the best
tennis player ever certainly the best on
Earth right now Novak Djokovic he is
unvaxxed he was unable to play in a
couple major tennis tournaments over the
past couple years his argument was hey
I'm young and healthy tennis it's just
one guy and another guy on the other
side and a one ball we're not breathing
all over each other I'm taking care of
myself I get plenty of Sun I eat right
I'm like the peak of physical health
like why should I take this vax they are
still not letting him in the United
States right now think about how
freaking insane that is I guess it
shouldn't be thought of as freaking
insane considering only two days ago the
harpies at the view let their own
audience take their masks off I mean for
me it's just like hard to believe that
people still live in that reality but
okay so that's happening right now no uh
Novak Djokovic cannot get in the United
States so uh Governor DeSantis over here
in the Free State of Florida he's trying
to come up with a creative way to make
it happen
which I think as you guys know you know
number one tennis player uh one of the
best ever he is being discriminated
against because he didn't take the mnra
kova jab and he never wanted to do it
from the beginning and you know what
there were people in Florida who never
wanted to do it and we fought for your
right to make that choice without losing
your job or having this stuff
and so
not only has he not wanted to take it we
now have the data to show these booster
shots aren't preventing you from getting
infected people get infected anyways and
so you know it's like okay now you have
this this this Rule and we're one of the
only countries in the world that has
this rule that you have to show shot
records to come in as a foreign visitor
on an airplane Djokovic has already had
covid you know there's something called
natural immunity which the CDC didn't
want to recognize but we all know is a
fact of life and so he poses zero risk
to the United States zero risk to the
State of Florida and zero risk to Miami
so he should be allowed to compete now I
would run a I would run a boat from the
Bahamas here for him I would do that a
hundred percent
but
[Applause]
we are going to have to smuggle in
tennis players on boats from the Bahamas
that's where we're at in this clown car
of endless stupidity but really guys
joking aside the federal government
still does not want unvaccinated people
in this country think how absolutely
insane that is and then put that in
contrast to the beginnings of covet when
we knew it was coming from Wuhan right
whether you thought it was coming from
the lab or from the wet Market or
whatever and Trump said hey we're going
to close the doors to China and everyone
called him racist right now when covet
is basically over we know that vaccines
don't work natural immunity does all of
the stuff we've you know all of the same
people have moved past it and we are
still trying to keep this guy out of the
United States do you think it has
anything to do with covet anymore or
could it have something to do with
control
[Music]
thank you